I'm Jocelyn I've been a filmmaker in New
York for about nine years now I recently
finished up my third written produced
second directed feature catch-22 based
on their written story by Sony sakru
which I am shamelessly plugging here by
having set the key art as my desktop
wallpaper and a few years ago I wrote a
book called filmmaking the hard way
which is a case study on the making of
my first feature all God's creatures and
for some reason or another film courage
just thinks that qualifies me to talk to
you about five things I wish I hadn't
known before I made a feature film with
no money so the first thing I wish I
have known before I try to make a film
with no money would have been that no
one is going to give you money to make
your first feature film and rightfully
so why would anyone give you money to do
something that is incredibly difficult
without having proven that you're
capable of having done it are capable of
doing it rather and you know that's just
kind of the way it works you're gonna
have to to get to create that piece of
work that demonstrates it's something
you can do you're going to have to do it
with little to no resources and you know
I think a lot of filmmakers walk into
this stuff you know for any number of
reasons be it they have a strong body of
work in some other aspect of the
industry music videos they have some
short film that crushed it I felt film
festival none of that matters none of
that is even remotely comparable to
building a feature-length 90-plus minute
film from the ground up and actually
seen it to fruition it's it's
it's impossible it's boy it's truly
about every film you see regardless of
the scope is a [ __ ] miracle so you
know you need to understand that you're
going to go into this and you're going
to have to scrape together whatever
resources you need to accomplish telling
your story with and from basically
nothing and just accept that so the
second thing I would have known going
into making all God's creatures would be
that this is kind of flipside to the
first point because you're not going to
have the resources that you need or want
or whatever to make this thing you need
to embrace the fact that you have those
constraints and and accept them and and
you know that acceptance can lead to
things that are actually creative
benefits to the project and the story I
always tell as an example this is all
God's creatures we needed this claw
machine that in the script was
supposedly in this movie Lobby and you
know we of course shop long and hard to
find a movie theatre that would let us
shoot there that happened to have a claw
machine and of course we couldn't find
that with no money so the whole time
we've been failing to find that I had
been walking by a deli at the corner
into my street up in Spanish Harlem I
looked at the time and this deli
happened to have a claw machine outside
on the sidewalk in front of the store
and you know I walked by one day and I
was like why in the hell don't we just
shoot the thing here we we have to shoot
this film in a couple weeks anyways we
got to figure something out let's just
do this and at the time it seemed like a
concession but in hindsight it you know
the film is a very dark gritty New York
story and shooting that scene which is
like you know a big spark in the love
story between the two main character is
such an important pivotal scene shooting
that in in the gritty aesthetic of a
New York sidewalk and Spanish Harlem is
so much more in line with what the film
is and needed to be then it would have
been have we shot it in a movie theater
lobby that was brightly lit and and you
know beautiful or whatever the aesthetic
of that would have been so you know
having constraints can be a benefit as
long as you accept it and you know are
open to using those constraints in a way
that gets you to the finish line in a
way you can deal with number three on
this little list is the value as the
producer on the project the value of the
bargaining chip you have in giving
someone their first feature film credit
and in the same way that you're doing
this project if it is your first feature
for the the purpose of showing that
you're capable of making the feature
that it is something that you know you
can do the same thing goes for every
single person that you'll need to make
it the bulk of people both actors and
crew probably are going to be doing this
for way less money to no money because
it's their first feature and and that on
a resume is a huge thing particularly
god forbid the film plays a few
festivals that are even remotely
reputable like even if it doesn't get
that far it's still having a feature
film on your resume shows that you can
do it and that's a very powerful thing
that you can use when trying to talk
Kajol weasal entire feature films worth
of work out of you know whatever crew
positions you need or actors to to get
the job done so number four is expect to
learn I started in the entertainment
industry as an actor and while doing
that instead of waiting for the phone to
ring I chose to start producing little
off-broadway shows as a way
to create work for myself and you know
so I had to teach myself how to produce
things and that was pretty much trial
and error thing you know [ __ ] things
up figuring it out as I went and while
producing I began to see find it
difficult rather to find material that I
liked that I thought was good for little
or no money and for that reason I
started writing and that required
reading Blake Snyder's sake the cat to
start and a million other books and and
trial and error and writing a lot of bad
things to be able to create a screenplay
that I believed in enough to produce and
after having done that a few times I
decided why not try to direct this thing
and to do that I had to teach myself how
to direct and figure that out by
probably [ __ ] it up a few times and
on this latest feature I you know
decided I was going to edit it and that
that would be a much cheaper option than
going out and paying and someone else to
do that so I had to teach myself how to
edit at least proficiently enough to to
put together of a feature-length film
and in doing that I taught myself how to
color correct and and you know the
beauty of being a filmmaker present-day
is that there are YouTube tutorials and
things you can Google to figure out how
to do just about anything they're not
just about anything anything and and you
know some my filmmaking heroes the
Duplass brothers Shaun Baker Joe
Swanberg are guys that have that kind of
mentality and that's that you know
regardless of what I have to do or learn
how to do or figure out to get this
thing to the finish line I'm just gonna
say your [ __ ] out and do it and and you
know I think some people start doing
this stuff thinking oh I'm a director or
you know a writer-director and I can't
handle the producing side of it or I
don't want to handle the briefs inside
of it and you know I to make stuff at
the node a low-budget level you cannot
have that mentality you have to be
willing to learn how to do and to
actually do every single part of the
process so the fifth and final thing
would be the sheer amount of time it
takes to take a feature film from
concept to asses sitting in front of the
screen watching it and you know just as
an example all guys creatures I started
writing in June of oh eight and it was
on store shelves through our distributor
in May of 2012 so that was nearly a four
year window that's me and three other
guys the figure heads on the project
worked tirelessly for no money to make
this thing happen and you know had I had
known that going into it how much time
and effort that would that would take I
might not have done it I hope that's not
the case I hope I still would have done
it but I you know I guess it's important
to know that going into it that it is a
ridiculously long road to get a feature
film made and out there and to do so you
really need to love the story that
you're trying to tell and and you know
that is probably of all these things the
most important component to have in
place before you walk into the process
is to really give a [ __ ] about telling
the story because there's no telling the
number of obstacles you have to overcome
to make that happen so don't make some
shitty film that you wouldn't want to
sit in a theater and watch make sure
it's something you care about because
that is going to be what carries you
through those really really shitty
nights where everything the sky is
falling
yeah so those are the five things that I
wish I had known
before I made my first feature with no
money now go make your [ __ ] thing